Sol
Ring is a Magic the Gathering card.
It was first printed in 1993 in Alpha,
the first print run of the first Magic
the Gathering set,
and went on to be printed in the other
three print runs, ending in spring of
1994.
It is one of the most powerful mana
artifacts in the game and has been
banned or restricted in most constructed
formats for basically its entire
existence.
It sat on the reserved list, a list of
cards that Wizards of the Coast has
promised not to reprint from 1996 until
2002,
at which point Wizards updated the
reserved list to allow reprints of the
first set's commons and uncommons.
The card commanded fairly high prices
all through the 2000s,
with it being reprinted in the limited
run from the Vault Relics,
but still keeping most of its value.
Then, it was reprinted in the first
Commander set in 2011 as one of two
cards included in all five of the set's
preconstructed decks.
The other card was Command Tower,
effectively a downsideless Mana
Confluence.
The reasoning for this choice on
Wizards' part was simple.
Sol Ring was considered by some to be a
must-include in the then-small Commander
format, since on account of it being
banned in Legacy, its low double-digits
price was pretty affordable for its
power level.
So, the precon decks should also include
Sol Ring.
I could say a lot about this logic.
Most prominently, that Sol Ring's
relative affordability was a product of
it not being played in large formats.
Printing sets specifically for EDH was a
great way to inflate the size of the
format, a process which, without a
reprint, would have caused a demand
spike with a fixed supply and increased
the price,
likely relegating Sol Ring to
higher-power level EDH decks.
It's a problem that solves itself, one
could argue.
Also, the precon Commander decks weren't
exactly well constructed. So, the idea
that they need to keep up with the decks
of long-time Commander players
is pretty laughable.
But, something you might notice is that
there's a small difference between me
and Wizards of the Coast.
I don't make money off of how many units
of the Commander precons get sold.
And they do.
So, I guess I'm a little biased that
way.
But, okay.
I think it would have been fine or even
advisable
to let Sol Ring's price soar as the
format's size grows.
Let it be a toy for the power gamers
alongside Mana Crypt, Moxen, and the
like.
I understand why some people might
disagree, but that's my opinion.
There are also people who have argued
that it should be banned, such as a
writer known as Chisarliscious 2 months
after the Commander sets release in
2011.
And well, unless somebody goes around
burning every single copy of Sol Ring on
Earth released after 2010,
a ban would really be the only solution.
But, it's not going to happen.
Commander's ban list is hot take alert
kind of a stupid mess that very clearly
underscores the difficulty of moderating
such a large format played in so many
different ways and with such a wide
potential pool of cards.
On top of this, Sol Ring has been
printed in over a dozen Commander sets.
Wizards have done their utmost to place
the card within the pantheon of EDH.
So, Sol Ring is here to stay.
But, what does that mean for the game?
What does the existence of wildly
powerful cards at a cheap price do to a
format like Commander?
One of the most compelling issues with
these cheap, powerful cards
is that they warp the way players look
at other cards.
Depending on the goals of a deck and how
it's constructed,
it might be looking for varying
quantities of mana rocks, counter
spells, draw spells, and so on.
You can build a framework for the deck
without looking at cards. For example,
going, "Okay,
this deck wants eight ramp spells, 10
draw spells, and 12 removal spells.
I should look through cards to find
these quantities of cards."
But, come on. Let's be honest.
This is not how most people build decks.
People see their options for ramp, draw,
and removal, and they just start adding
cards.
The specific cards being considered then
have an impact on how many of that sort
of card end up in the final deck.
As a counter scenario, one can imagine a
universe in which players' removal
options solely consist of Naturalize,
Murder, Lava Coil, and Banishing Light,
to be played in whatever quantities the
player wants.
In this universe, a player is forced to
spend more time thinking about questions
like,
"How much might I worry about
enchantments and artifacts? How many
creature removal spells do I need to
deal with opposing pressure and win
cons?"
The question isn't what specific removal
spells a player needs,
but rather how much of these sort of
stock options.
Back in the real world, things end up
working out a bit different than this.
This is especially pronounced if a
player is using a website like EDHREC or
some other metric that orders cards by
popularity or quality.
If you're looking for counter spells in
Scryfall ordered by EDHREC rank,
as I have been spotted doing from time
to time,
you first see Counterspell, a card
that'll set you back a dollar.
Great. I love it.
Then, you see a couple of other options
that are similar with a downside,
as well as a couple that cost a lot of
money.
By the time you get down to your
standard staples, your kitchen table
kings, your modern machinations of yore,
it's looking a lot less tempting.
You have your Mana Leak type cards that
fall off fast in power in later turns.
You have your more specialized options.
And then you have your counter spells
that commit the cardinal sin of costing
three mana.
It's easy to imagine a player seeing the
rapid price increases and power
decreases that happen when you scroll
downward from Counterspell,
going,
"Well, okay.
I guess I'll run Counterspell and a
couple of these other ones,
and then I'll have the good counter
spells within my budget."
Now, it should be mentioned that
Counterspell is an incredibly powerful
card.
Most other counter options that players
can run are worse than it, yes,
but I'd guess that most blue decks want
lowercase C counter spells enough that
they'd benefit from running cards that
are kind of a lot worse than
Counterspell.
A joke in my playgroup is to respond to
the question of, "Oh, what does that
card do?" with something like,
"Oh, yeah, it's like a worse Sol Ring."
or, "Oh, yeah, it's basically a worse
version of Lightning Bolt."
The joke here is that these statements
tell you almost nothing about the actual
power of a card.
It's like somebody asking how old a
person is, and you saying, "Oh, yeah,
they're younger than Henry Kissinger."
Helpful, thank you.
As a point of contrast, we can consider
other types of cards somebody might
choose to run,
ones whose power is less obvious.
It's pretty easy to go, "Oh, Wizard's
Retort? That's strictly worse than
Counterspell."
But what about if I want, say, a card
that generates value when I play
creature spells?
All right, scryfall,
let's go green cards that have whenever
cast and creature in their text,
and let's rank them based on EDHrec, and
there.
Well, okay, so there's Beast Whisperer,
and there's The Great Henge,
and there's Silverback Elder, and
there's Primeval Bounty, and there's
Glimpse of Nature, and there's Wild
Pair, and there's Masked Admirers, and
there's Vengevine.
So, which ones are the bad ones?
Which one should I add, and where should
I stop adding them?
These cards are pulled from all across
the 57 ordered cards that pop up with my
search inputs.
Some are more flexible, or more bursty,
or lower to the ground,
but analyzing them is a much trickier
value proposition than looking at
Counterspells.
It's possible I did the math on my deck
ahead of time and went, "Okay, I need
two or three of these cards, preferably
at least one in the four to five mana
range, and at least one in the six to
seven mana range."
But if I didn't,
gee, there are sure a lot of
good-looking cards here.
I could run worse Counterspell or worse
Sol Ring, or I could run more of these.
And counter spells aren't the only thing
to get neglected.
If I'm looking for creature removal,
Swords to Plowshares and Path to Exile
are both under two bucks and absurdly
powerful.
With other white creature removal being
much worse or much more expensive.
If I'm looking for artifact removal, red
has Abrade and Vandalblast. With other
options, once again, being worse or more
expensive.
If I'm looking for general-purpose draw
for blue, there are a few low-budget
options.
Mystic Remora is fabulous, especially
with its price halved by a Dominaria
Remastered reprint.
And Mulldrifter, Treasure Cruise, and
Archmage Emeritus all have decent spots
in several different archetypes.
But beyond that, things get weaker, more
specialized, or more expensive.
If somebody isn't setting out a
framework for their deck, it's easy to
imagine underdoing it on the more
generalist stuff and overdoing it on the
more synergistic stuff.
And a deck running too much synergistic
stuff
and not enough general stuff is at risk
of getting itself into a bimodal pickle.
A state where it either falls on its
face after getting a key piece removed
or it goes on to a Mach 10 march toward
victory.
A basic issue with having cards like Sol
Ring widely available is that card
quality in a given deck gets a lot less
consistent at lower budgets.
If you're building a deck with a budget
in the high hundreds or more, you might
include Counterspell alongside Mana
Drain and a couple other pricey
counters.
Along with whichever cheaper ones best
fit your deck and play situations.
If you needed some green ramp, you might
also include Nature's Lore along with
Three Visits, a clone from Portal Three
Kingdoms.
A set that was almost exclusively sold
in East Asian markets.
Until a series of reprints recently, the
only way to get this card was to pay
upwards of $50 for the Portal Three
Kingdoms version.
And honestly, Portal Three Kingdoms
could be a video topic all on its own.
But I'm not going to dwell on it further
today.
All this is just to say that shelling
out money leads to deck consistency.
There are certainly powerful cards that
are cheap due to wide reprints or
another reason, such as Sol Ring,
Counterspell, and Swords to Plowshares.
But there's an even sneakier type of
budget card.
The ones that cost $0.
A quick anecdote. I recently built a
Marwyn, the Nurturer of Antiquity deck.
It's an equipment's deck. You throw a
bunch of equipments on Marwyn, and then
tap them to generate mana and value.
I kind of built it as a meme, but it's a
genuinely delightful mid-power level
aggro deck.
Anyway, after ordering the $40 worth of
mostly random bulk I needed for the
list,
I sat staring at the Sword of the
Animist and Sword of Forge and Frontier
I had in my collection.
They cost no money to add and would be
so good in the deck.
I put them in the deck for a few games,
but they had such a warping effect that
I decided to take them out.
My deck's mana and value engines were
pretty solid for an aggro deck, but
decidedly reasonable in scope.
While Explorer's Scope and Rogue's
Gloves both feel very appropriate within
the list, when I played Sword of Forge
and Frontier, it felt like a totally
different deck.
And I know the fact that that's within
the realm of possibility naturally
shifts the way my opponents will think
about my deck.
Ultimately, it wasn't meant to be a
particularly high-powered deck, nor
could it hope of performing like a
high-powered deck on the current budget.
So, I cut the swords.
The point being made here is that you
should add cards to a deck under
consideration of how they'll impact the
games you play with the deck,
even if you own the cards and they're
free to add.
My quasi-meme equipments deck has a
handful of specific weaknesses, and
adding power cards to the deck doesn't
help it manage those weaknesses with any
consistency. It just makes people want
to play better decks against it.
An even better example is graveyard
decks.
Graveyard synergies are wide-ranging,
fun, and potentially quite powerful,
but they exist within a game that has a
lot of really heavy-duty graveyard hate.
There are the options like Tormod's
Crypt and Rest in Peace, which
straightforwardly demolish graveyard
strategies,
and even cards like Nihil Spellbomb and
Bojuka Bog, which do so without even
spending a card, and with the latter
dodging counterspells on top of all
that.
All this to say,
decks heavily based around graveyards
need to make a decision.
Accept the need to be resilient against
this stuff, usually by winning quickly
or being loaded with counters for the
hate,
or
play at a power level where these hate
cards are less common.
This puts a lot of mid-power graveyard
decks in an awkward spot.
Adding stronger synergies will lead to
crushing unprepared decks even more than
before,
but will still end up with getting
wholesale dunked on by hate cards unless
the efficiency of the deck is vastly
improved to guarantee quicker or more
abrupt wins.
There's not necessarily a right or wrong
answer here, but my mantra is that if
you don't want to play higher power
level,
don't play higher power level.
Another example of this is cheap
infinite combos.
Namely, Niv-Mizzet and Curiosity.
I've known people who went,
"Well, this deck is running red and
blue, and I've got the cards sitting
right here.
Why not add them?"
If you're purely looking to increase the
power level of your deck, this is fine
logic.
But, adding an infinite combo to your
deck changes the whole dynamic of games
once people know it's there.
As a frequent enjoyer of aggro, I often
find myself asking the question,
"How will each of my opponents be trying
to win this game?"
If the answer goes from, I don't know,
drakes or something, to an infinite
combo that requires very little setup,
I'm probably going to be hitting that
player with my creatures, and they're
definitely going to deserve it.
As another anecdote about building decks
for the types of games you want to play,
my brother recently got his first
Commander deck, a decently built Jodah
deck.
In a night with several EDH games,
everybody pulled out one of the more
powerful lists every time he played the
Jodah deck,
resulting in games where he was doing a
lot, but also eating a lot of removal
spells and needing to deal with a bunch
of powerful nonsense from other people.
The games were close, but the only game
he actually won that night was in a
lower power level game where he borrowed
my Meria deck.
At the end of the night, he proclaimed
that he needed to build a lower power
level deck.
To bring this scattered assortment of
points back down to Earth a little,
let's think about Sol Ring once again.
A player running a budget deck might run
the ever-powerful Sol Ring alongside
Hedron Archive, locket, or other slower
mana ramp.
Now, let's consider this effect for
draw.
They're running a single Consecrated
Sphinx that they happen to have in their
collection
alongside cards like Treasure Cruise,
Blue Sun's Zenith, and Body of
Knowledge.
Add in a few other examples like this,
and it's not hard to construct an
outline for their deck
where 10% of the time they chain very
powerful cards and explode the entire
table.
But most of the rest of the time, their
deck performs on a much lower caliber.
Some might ask, "Well, what's the
problem with this?"
And well, the answer to that is
complicated because EDH is a complicated
format with a variety of different
players and power levels
and a format where table politics and
the threat perceptions of individual
players play a key role.
In this environment, individual power
cards might not necessarily pose a
problem.
You know, in my play groups, Sol Ring is
looked at with a minor eye roll. Uh
"Nice draw, bro."
If the Sol Ring player gets out of hand,
you hit them a bit, and hopefully things
calm down.
Commander is theoretically a
self-balancing format,
but the more inconsistently powerful a
deck becomes,
the trickier it becomes for other people
to conceptualize the power level of that
deck.
At a certain point, the self-balancing
will simply be hitting your deck with
their creatures or picking a more
powerful deck to begin with to play
against you
because they don't want to contend with
the puzzle box that you're presenting
them with.
This video was a little meandering, so
let's try and recap some of the key
points here.
Sol Ring is an absurdly powerful card,
and I kind of hate putting it in my
lower-powered decks, but it's not going
to get banned. Nor would banning it
particularly constitute some kind of
fundamental good for the format, in my
opinion.
Counterspell is also a very strong card
and absolutely should not be held as a
power level baseline for counterspells,
even if the card is called, well,
counterspell.
If you're looking for mana rocks,
counterspells, or really any other sort
of supporting effect, you should ideally
think about how many of these sorts of
effects your deck needs before going
looking,
or at least be careful while looking at
cards.
A deck built with the tools it needs,
even at a slightly lower power level,
will perform well with much more
consistency than the deck that only
picks the strongest three to four cards
for categories of cards where the deck
is really looking for more like eight or
10.
An additional point I could flesh out
more at a later date is that sometimes
the strongest option isn't even the best
for the deck.
If I want to drop my four mana commander
on curve as often as possible,
it might be correct to run lower power
one or two drop mana ramp rather than
cultivate, Kodama's Reach, or Harrow.
Similarly, some decks might be much less
worried about running three or four mana
counterspells if they're cheaper or
better suited to the deck than the
options that cost less mana.
Additionally, players should add cards
to their deck under consideration of how
those cards will fit into the sort of
game they want to play.
I could add Torment of Hailfire to my
turbo Battle Cruiser Glissa deck, and
that would probably make it stronger,
but my opponents are going to view the
deck wildly differently if they know I
have an I win button.
Playing a truly absurd number of lands
is the goal of the deck and the fun part
of the deck, and I don't want people to
feel like they'll get flattened
instantly if they let me get to 20
lands.
Even if you own a card and it's sitting
right there in front of you waiting to
get added in a casual EDH group, it
might still be correct to leave it out
for the sake of keeping the deck at a
consistent power level.
As mentioned earlier, if you're running
a graveyard-centered deck, you could
juice up the power level of your
graveyard strategies.
But, if you're not prepared to deal with
heavy-duty hate cards,
you're going to be running a mess of a
deck that smashes fun casual decks, but
gets demolished at the first sight of a
Relic of Progenitus.
And, to bring things back to earlier
points,
if you're running just the most powerful
of a certain effect, like ramp, removal,
or draw,
you're going to have a handful of games
where you get those and pop off super
hard,
and other games where your deck is a
clunky mass of high-cost synergy cards
that fails to accomplish much of
anything.
But, the bottom line is, if you have a
time machine and several million dollars
for bribes, we should go back in time
together and prevent Wizards of the
Coast from printing Sol Ring in
Commander 2011.